les poteaux bien avant
Et elles offrent, ce printemps,
aux électeurs, le bouquet
de leur histoire.
12 visages sur les affiches.
le siège laissé vacant
par Catherine Four
- L'ex-dbre mairesbre mairesbree
de Longueuil, dont
Marie-Victorin représente
un dixième de laa populatia pop.
François Legault, qui a laissé
passer l'hiver avant d'organiser
l'élection, la voit comme
FRANÇOIS LEGAULTpremier ministrc
- Je pense que c'est un test
d'abord pour le Parti Québécois.
historique est sans équivoque,
ou presque. Sur 13 scrutins,
un seul a échappé au PQ
au profit des Libéraux.
- 40 ans que je suis ici.
Oh ça s'est dégradé beaucoup.
- Ce qui se dégrade surtout
en élection partielle, c'est
le taux de participation.
Alors que les dernières
en moyenne autour de 70 %
de votants, le taux est tombé
à 25 % lors de la partielles, qe
qui mobiliserait l'électorat
le 11 avril?ut
sauver la planète.
- Bien moi les priest
l'environnement et la santé.
- Le logement c'est une autre
affaire aussi. Il , présente, p,
l'explosion des prix
des logements.ur situé
au coeur du comté, Louis-Pascal
prend lel'électeur
n'est pan'est pan'est pan'est p.
LOUIS-PASCAL MUNANDO-FERRARO,gét
- J'ai l'impression que les gens
dans le quartier se sentent
- Mais, la préoccupation
qui revient le plus,
c'est le logement.
- Je vous dirais que c'est
un mélange de tout. Tu sais,
des logements insalubres,
c'est pas un quartier facile.
- Alexandre vient d'ailleurs
d'en visiter un.
- Un 4 et demi, 1150, rien
ce quartier, oui,
- Ici, deux tiers de
la population est locataire.
Et le nombre de plaintes,
a doublé depuis 2 ans.
CAROLINE VOHL, organisatrice
communautaire, logement Rive-Sud
- Justement ce bâtiment-là,
c'est un bon exemple. C'est
illégale. Il ya une détresse,
des gens qui nous enenenenenen
pleurant, des gens âgés qui nous
appellent et qui doivent quitter
leur logement et qont
des nouveaux arrivants, victimes
de discrimination,
des situations vraiment
insultant de voir qu'il y a
des partis qui pre
cette situation-là au sérieux.
- La plupart des candidatss'enge
de logements sociaux, mais tous
ne s'entendent pas sur les motst
pas encore nommée par
s, c'est un total
non-sens.
- Le béton et l'as
de tout le secteur où la voiture
personnest
encore reine.ANDRÉANDRÉANDRÉANÉl
rég., environnement, Montérégiei
sont encore très dépendants
de l'auto solo, donc on a à peu
près 70 % des déplacements
ville de Lville de Lville de Lvl
qui se fait encore en auto solo.
- Pourtant, l'environnement
revient régulièrement comme
une priorité chez les électeurs.
Et il n'y a pas l'embarras
champêtres ici.
- On est dans un des rares
milieux naturels de Marie-
Victorin
Donc, on est sur u
assez gazonné, avec un petit
milieu avec des espècesantes jué
de nous.
- En bord de route.
du pont Jacques-Cartier.
- Devant l'immense défi
climatique, à l'échelle
d'une ciits pas
peut aussi être un vecteur
de changement, comme ce projet
appuyé par le provincial.- Soust
un projet qu'on vise
à déminéraliser à la main, donc
pour recréer un îlot
de fraicheur. Un projet,
justement, les bénéfices pour
un milieu scolaire qui était
complètement asphalté, manque
vraiment d'ombrage pour
les élèves.
Le ou la future heureuse élue
r longtemps.
Peu importe le programme qui lui
vaudra les suffrages, il faudra
ne pour
les élections générales
du 3 octobre prochain.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, Longueuil.